ich hatte schon mal in einem meiner
letzten videos smartphones verändern
unser selbst werden wir jetzt langsam zu
cyborgs die nur noch mit maschinen
existieren können werden wir so abhängig
von assistenzsystemen computern und
sensoren dass wir ohne sie komplett
aufgeschmissen sind es ist gar nicht so
abwegig dass wir uns schon bald in diese
richtung entwickeln werden
2 box sind in science fiction film wesen
die halb mensch halb roboter mechanisch
ihre arbeit verrichten
bei den box in star trek sind sie wie
ein ameisenstaat organisieren aber was
macht die heutige technik mit uns sind
wir schon auf dem weg dorthin ist es
überhaupt nötig irgend etwas zu
implantieren um ähnlich wie bei einem
cyborg mit der technik verbunden zu sein
wir alle kennen die antwort wir haben
sie mit unserem smartphone in den händen
natürlich nicht mit jedem smartphone
werden heute bereits schritte gezählt
und zurückgelegte strecken gemessen und
es kommt immer mehr dazu die neue apple
watch wird ständig den herzschlag
überwachen die waage im badezimmer kann
zb das gewicht regelmäßig melden und
weitere daten der schlaf kann auf wunsch
vom telefon überwacht werden und so
weiter und so fort
die technik rückt immer mit ihren zwei
schlafen vorteilen immer näher an uns
ran und macht sich irgendwann
unentbehrlich es ist ganz klar zu
unserem vorteil
diejenigen die die technik nutzen werden
länger leben aber macht die technik auch
etwas mit ihnen genau das scheint zu
geschehen an sich erstmal ist es nichts
schlimmes wenn ich mich aber veränderung
nicht zu vermerken ist dass wirklich
wünschenswert wir kennen das alles schon
vom navigationssystem und den karten
apps inzwischen auch egal ob ich hier in
paris meinen weg mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln suche zu fuß oder mit
dem auto unterwegs bin überall habe ich
maps ein navigationssystem oder sonst
irgendein hilfsmittel niemand naja fast
niemand benutzt noch eine karte da kann
es passieren dass man irgendwo ankommt
aber keine ahnung hat wo man eigentlich
ist ein bisschen irritierend ist dass
schon die technik hat uns hier nicht nur
arbeit abgenommen
sie hat uns auch ein mündig sie hat
entschieden wie wir zu dem ort gelangen
zudem wir wollen uns lässt sie zudem im
unklaren darüber wo wir uns denn nun
genau befinden würde ich mich jedenfalls
100 prozent aufs navi verlassen
dann wüsste ich oft aus den
informationen die ich dort bekomme nicht
zuverlässig wo ich eigentlich bin
aber was macht das mit mir verändert
mich diese bereitwillige abgabe von
kompetenzen
eine studie amerikanischer
wissenschaftler kamen zu einem
beruhigenden ergebnis für iphone
besitzer haben sie ein iphone dabei wenn
sie geprüft werden also ein test
schreiben sind ihre ergebnisse besser
der clou dafür müssen sie das iphone
nicht mehr nutzen es reicht es in der
nähe zu haben
die forscher vermuten dass und jetzt
kommt der punkt das iphone eine
erweiterung unseres selbst werden könnte
und das fehlen deshalb einen negativen
psychologischen zustand hervorruft wie
bitte ohne smartphone quasi nur noch ein
halber mensch
ehrlich gesagt finde ich das schon ein
bisschen spucke und die neueste studie
zu dem thema persönlichkeitsveränderung
durch moderne technik die ist wirklich
ein wenig bescheuert wissenschaftler der
marken psychological association haben
nämlich untersucht wie sich die nutzung
von suchmaschinen im internet auf die
selbstwahrnehmung auswirkt und das ist
eigentlich albern wenn sich dann doch
weit reichenden konsequenzen hätte die
bloße nutzung einer suchmaschine führt
nämlich schon dazu dass sich die nutzer
für klüger als anderen menschen halten
das ist wirklich ein bisschen change was
passiert selbst dann wenn sie überhaupt
nichts finden
jetzt mögen das manche als irgendwie
eine randnotiz abtun aber ich finde das
bedenklich denn nicht da passiert das
was ich für sehr schwierig finde unsere
persönlichkeit verändert sich ohne dass
wir es merken
das führt dann zu riesigen
kommunikationsproblem weil mein
gegenüber weiß es ja gar nicht und kann
dann zu zwischenmenschlichen großen
schwierigkeiten führen
wir verstehen uns einfach nicht mehr und
vor allem gehen wir so eine sehr
seltsame sind lose mit der genutzten
technik ein
der erste schritt zum cyborg
ja und wie wir übrigens mit neuer
technik schon heute zu einem realen
cyborg werden in diesem thema hat sich
cedric vor kurzem beschäftigt sind wir
auf dem weg zum super mensch das gibt es
in diesem video zum blog und zur app mit
täglichen news geht es hier
und was meint ihr ist die schnelle
technische entwicklung moderner technik
eine gefahr für uns werden wir uns ohne
es zu bemerken verändern diskutiertes
mit mir und den kommentaren und was
können wir vielleicht dagegen tun also
bis dann bleibt dran